una de las ideas principales del libro
de thomas piketty es que el rendimiento
del capital r
es mayor que el crecimiento de la
economía lo cual puede llevar a la
desigualdad el cual es un subproducto
natural del crecimiento de la economía
del mercado capitalista
alguien puede argumentar que siempre
existirá algo de desigualdad conforme va
creciendo la economía y algunas personas
se vuelven emprendedoras y tienen suerte
otras personas no tienen tanta suerte
algunos trabajan más duro y otros no
tanto algunas personas pueden ubicar
bien su capital y otros no sin embargo
en su forma extrema esto puede ser malo
para la democracia demasiado poder puede
ocasionar problemas y en el peor de los
casos este comienza a conducirse solo e
incluso a perjudicar el crecimiento
económico al no tener suficientes
personas que puedan ser consumidores
porque no tengan el ingreso suficiente
lo que quiero que nos enfoquemos aquí no
es tanto en si es que estas causalidades
se encuentran aquí o que tanto
deberíamos preocuparnos por ellas
no es dar una opinión de si estoy de
acuerdo o no con todo esto o com parte
del libro sino darles un marco de
referencia ya que yo creo que el libro
de a pie a conversaciones interesantes y
mucho material para análisis y también
estimula el pensamiento crítico ese es
el objetivo el como ustedes pueden
reflexionar o pensar sobre estos temas
para que lleguen a sus propias
conclusiones lo que quiero hacer aquí es
mostrarles algunas circunstancias en las
que el rendimiento del capital pudiera
ser mayor al crecimiento económico y ver
si esto pudiera ser un modelo de
desigualdad sabemos que esta conexión de
aquí es algo más difícil para dibujar la
implicación necesaria pero esto no
necesariamente será el caso siempre para
ilustrar esto imaginemos una economía
cuya única producción son las manzanas
aquí dibujo la totalidad de esa economía
vamos a copiarla y pegarla para mostrar
el crecimiento económico
digamos que en el año 1 se produjeron
mil manzanas
y en el año dos tendremos un crecimiento
económico de cee del año 1 al año 2 se
va a ser igual al 2% el 2% de 1000 serán
20 manzanas más por lo que en el año 2
la economía produce mil 20 manzanas
ahora digamos que en el año 1 de las mil
manzanas producidas 500 de ellas vamos a
dividir el dibujo a la mitad se van a ir
a los dueños del capital
quinientas al capital recordemos que
esta es una economía sencilla que solo
tiene una única industria y los dueños
del capital serán los dueños de las
manzanas o dueños de la maquinaria o de
lo necesario para cosechar las manzanas
y digamos que las otras 500 manzanas van
a la mano de obra 500 van a mano de obra
imaginemos que el valor del capital aquí
en manzanas ya que suponemos que es lo
único que se produce si el dueño de el
manzanar quisiera venderlo quien quiera
comprarla tendrá que dar cuatro mil
manzanas
con estas condiciones cuál será el
rendimiento del capital en el año 1
rendimiento
del capital
en el año 1 va a ser 500 manzanas
divididas entre el costo o el valor del
capital que son de cuatro mil manzanas
lo que nos dará 5 entre 40 es un octavo
lo que es un 12.5 por ciento veamos qué
sucede en el año 2 veremos cuál es el
rendimiento del capital en ese año y lo
compararemos con el crecimiento de aquí
digamos que todo lo del año 1 se
reinvierte en el año 2 por lo que ahora
el valor del capital
es de 4500 manzanas no necesariamente
usaron las manzanas como capital sino
que quizá usaron estas 500 manzanas
extra para comprar maquinaria o comprar
más terreno etcétera y también
imaginemos que la mano de obra recibió
un aumento de sueldo de manera que
nuevamente sólo 500 manzanas van a los
dueños del capital aunque esto no
siempre es el caso a veces son los
dueños del capital los que reciben el
aumento pero digamos que en esta
situación siguen recibiendo sólo
quinientas manzanas
y en este otro lado tenemos que 520 van
a la mano de obra 520 van a mano de obra
cuál será ahora el rendimiento del
capital seguirán siendo 500 manzanas
divididas entre 4500 manzanas
lo que es igual a 1 entre 9 veamos
nuestra calculadora para encontrar el
valor y vemos que uno entre 9 y 0.1 11 o
sea que será aproximadamente de 11.1 por
ciento la razón para mostrarles este
ejemplo es que muestra una situación en
donde r es mayor que se el rendimiento
de capital es de 12.5 por ciento en el
año 1 y 11.1 por ciento en el año 2 por
lo que ambos números son más grandes que
el crecimiento de toda la economía pero
incluso cuando esto está sucediendo no
tenemos un aumento de la desigualdad de
aquí obviamente elegí los números de tal
manera que quedara así pude haberlos
elegido de tal manera que quedara al
revés pero en esta situación no es
necesariamente el caso que al r ser
mayor que se ha fuerza aumente la
desigualdad en futuros vídeos veremos
unas hojas de cálculo en donde veremos
que si r permanece constante con un
valor fijo mayor que c
entonces aumentará la desigualdad pero
la razón por la que les mostré esto es
para mostrarles que si tenemos una erre
mayor que se durante un solo periodo de
tiempo no necesariamente significará que
aumente la desigualdad en este caso la
mano de obra recibió una mayor fracción
del total del ingreso nacional y de
nuevo la conexión entre mano de obra y
capital y la desigualdad en el ingreso
es que en general el ingreso que va a la
mano de obra es un mejor indicador del
ingreso que reciben los cuartiles más
bajos de la población y el ingreso que
va al capital es un mejor indicador del
ingreso que recibe el percentil superior
o de 100 más alto ya que el capital
tiende a concentrarse en las secciones
superiores